[Music]
I'd like to welcome everybody to
tonight's class on just tactics we're
going to cover I'm taking examples from
the book by Sigrid tarish called the
game of chess he has the whole section
on middle game attacks against the
opposing king tonight's subject is the
under defended back row allowing various
kinds of checkmates on your opponent's
home row or back row but before we get
started I just like to say my name is
Jim McLaughlin I'm a chess master I've
been playing chess since I was in high
school about 50 years now like each
person introduce themselves and say how
long they've been playing chess you
learned before I did I was taught when I
was in grade school by my uncle but I
didn't get serious about it till I got
to high school and all the kids were
playing chess so that's when I started
really started okay well again the back
row mate so this first example just gets
the idea across wait to move and win and
of course it's ripped to d8 checkmate
now the next example is almost as simple
so what we run through it quickly and
we'll get into some more interesting
ones now in this case we have the the
double works on the D file Black has the
double works on the e-file unfortunately
for black it's White's move so again
it's just rook to the eighth check rook
takes rook takes checkmate so that's the
general idea now will you get into some
more interesting examples in this
example it's way to play and win you can
see that the white rooks are lined up
one on e3 and one on a one giving a lot
of power along that efile
of course there's the pawn in the way
yeah there's two white to black center
pawns one at East six and d5 the Queen
defends the pawns as does the rook on e8
but notice that the rook on EA tis only
defended once by the Queen so if we can
break through there we would threaten
where it takes rook winning winning the
rook so that kind of gives us an idea
now I'd like to put it out there to the
audience who would suggest the when he
move for for white what do you think is
the winning move okay well Queen takes
d5 he black can answer Queen takes Queen
and you can't really break through yeah
so you can't this does not involve a
sacrifice this example you've got to put
pressure on those two Center puns how
can we bring another piece of pawn to
attack those Center pawns that's that's
the correct move so obviously the threat
is pawn takes pawn and black can't
respond pawn takes pawn because that
pawn on e6 is pinned by the threat of
rook takes or a check so that's the
threat it's not totally clear what the
best move is for black but the author
helps us out in this example is he has
black make and immediate blender so
let's do the blunder and then we'll
figure out the win okay
pawn takes pawn he would have done
better to defend that pawn with maybe
the work on f7 to d7 and not to pawn
takes pawn anyway now we do have a
winning combination
what's White's winning move here yeah
okay so the thread of course is rook
takes rook and Anwar to threatening the
Queen so black responds rook takes
circly and now what's the move and Queen
back now what Queen takes Queen that's a
correct way to do it
leading to checkmate very good okay now
in this position it's more complicated
than what we've looked at let's analyze
the position a little bit white is
obviously the attacker the Queen and
Bishop are attacking that knight on c6
as is the white rook on c1 now the white
bishop on e3 is not attacking anything
nor is the knight on f3 but notice that
there's a work on f1 that can slide over
to d1 where it's protected by the Queen
and the rook and it would threaten the
black queen and the black queen would
have to retreat somewhere so that's
pretty much it from whites point of view
there are no pawns interacting so no
pawn moves on either side make any sense
now let's look at black's resources
blacks looks like his knight on c6 looks
like it's well defended he's got a pawn
on b7 protecting the knight he's got the
knight on e7 and he's got the queen the
big drawback in blacks position is the
fact that his bishop hasn't moved from
its starting position and blocks the
rooks so the rooks are not protecting
each other that gives us as white the
opportunity to strike now if it was
blacks move he could defend everything
quite easily just by moving that Bishop
on c8 to 6 then the rooks would protect
each other
the
Bishop would help protect the f7 pawn
and black would be perfectly safe so
white to play and win we've looked at
most oh the other thing worth noting
look at the bad King King position for
black he's in the corner behind three
pawns and our goal is to get I work or a
queen on that back rank and deliver
checkmate so keep that in mind who who
would suggest the winning a winning move
for white yeah that's the right move it
forces the Queen back and now the rook
is lined up on that Rickon d8 which is
once the Queen moves away it will only
be defended by the knight on c6 right
okay so the Queen just drops back one
square to e6 and where she can continue
to defend the knight on c6 go ahead g5
alright let's look at that Knight to g5
obviously the Queen's going to have to
move unless black wants to do Rick takes
her a check for some reason and I don't
think that was really help him because
the the rook just got the other word
comes over and may be able to go up to
d8 anyway it might help him know yeah I
think rook takes your check would help
him in this case black desert takes her
a checked it when you're defending it
helps to exchange off the opponent's
pieces so that's one major idea so let's
do that
rook takes
yeah let's look at g4 were threatening
to trade Queens anyway and we're on the
white rook I think that I think white
wins in this case though with the move
Bishop takes Knight now what should
black do the threat is rook to d8 huh
well then his King comes over and can
threaten to do King takes net I like the
threat of work to DA threatening an
immediate checkmate and don't forget we
just took a piece off of the board and
the bit and if Queen takes Queen the
bishop takes back and or a piece up so
let's look at this a little deeper what
can black do this threat is rook to d8
check yeah a knight takes Bishop that's
good that's good okay now we can't do
Queen takes Knight because he would have
a queen takes for a check mate
but we could do rook to d8 check and
what would black do okay look it opened
up a nice line for our queen and we'd
get checkmate so apparently Queen to g4
is not sufficient we have to move our
queen somewhere but I got an idea let's
try Queen to f6 here the queen guards
the d8 square after Bishop takes Knight
knight Knight takes
Bishop takes Knight knight takes then
rook doesn't work because I would have
night - what might work work down check
I drop I do Queen takes Rickey to have
Knight takes pawn checked working the
king and queen let's look at that
so Bishop it looks like in this case
Bishop takes a knight looks like it wins
- the threat is rook to d8 and if Knight
takes this is kind of a cute move here
if Knight takes we still have Queen the
ei checkmate
and if Queen takes which I was thinking
I could defend what he has Knight takes
pawn check yeah and he should win that
game because after yeah yeah he should
win because the black King position is
open even though the materials about
balance the remaining Bishop and Queen
how to figure out a way to win some
ponds by checking the King
all right well rook takes rook didn't
work too good let's see
all right so here we're saying here
let's take yeah I don't see a defense
well let's let's do that again
rook takes rook check where it takes
rook now we tried Queen to g4 and we
tried Queen to f6 I don't think there's
any other moves so I'm going to say
whoever said Knight to g5 that's a good
move let's go back and see what the
author says should happen here's the
winning variation that the author gives
Bishop takes Knight he's destroying the
guard of the d8 rook Knight takes wait a
second Knight takes now rather
spectacular Queen takes Knight obviously
Queen takes Queen it would be rook takes
rook checkmate
pawn takes Queen rook takes rook check
Queen back or takes Queen checkmate and
oh the only move not to get checkmate is
Bishop up but remember we took a piece
so White's the piece up and he just
takes the pawn he wins the game a piece
up so I guess there were two ways to win
Bishop takes Knight and the other move
that someone suggested Knight to g5 very
good let's go on to the next example
this looks like that checkmate we saw
earlier where white played rook to dat
rook takes rook takes rook rook back or
it takes but there's a defense here it's
pretty simple so just run through it
work to d8 a blunder would be recruit
but you have the nice withdrawal of that
rook the rooks protect each other and
actually this is a drawing
game so rook takes rook we're and you
see that there's three pawns on each
side so there's no winning chances for
either side the point that the author's
point was that some beginners would fail
to realize they could retreat that work
on e4 to ei which is the key defensive
move let's see what we have here yes it
is black it's black to play and win
does anyone see the winning move for
black notice that the two rooks are
lined up and would love to play rook to
d1 check
it's adequately defended right now by
rook takes rook takes or a queen takes
rook rook to d2 doesn't work see that
bishop on f4 that can come back and take
it so the ideas can you draw the Queen
away from protecting the d1 square what
move does that for black remember that
the theme is a back row mate you want to
be headed toward the the the no no it it
may be a series of moves it only
ultimately ends in a mate
through the back rank in this case
White's first rank all right well that's
a good idea
you threatened I did you move the rook
you threatened a discovered attack on
the Queen you might do work to D one
check but I could give up the Queen and
get two rooks for my trouble couldn't I
two rooks are supposed to be
approximately even so that's not as
clear-cut as the author solution anybody
have any other ideas out
okay how about pawn takes Bishop and
that gives me an experiment I'm
checkmating me on the back row all right
now remember I said think about drawing
the White Queen away the Queen's
protecting d1 what other squares the
Queen protecting and I'm the queen side
b2 Queen takes b2 is the solution
Queen takes Queen she no longer guards
the d1 squared and the work down leads
to check mark and the threat is Queen
takes Queen there that's the checkmate
okay let's go into the next one
White has the two rooks lined up on that
d6 pawn black has the working Queen
lined up on the e-file but the White
King can retreat if he has to the White
King can move up to that whole h2 behind
the H pawn that tells me that this is
white to play and win see how the black
King is stuck behind his three pawns so
if we can get back there it would be
checkmate yeah I think we have to lower
ice our sights a little bit I don't see
an immediate way to break through and
get checkmate so what that leaves the
bishop unprotected and black could do
rook takes Bishop well but the Rick is
protected by the black Queen so but the
idea is good F for the idea is to drive
the rook away how about if we just move
that Bishop to f4 then we have the
bishop and the Queen and the two rooks
lined up on that d6 pawn don't we I
think that d6 pawn is a goner and once
we get down there maybe
we can break through so let's look at
Bishop to f4 oh no it's not Bishop
before it it's Bishop to h6 threatening
checkmate the reason this works see how
the Queen it actually could take the
bishop but that leaves the work on e5
protected by the pawn but the pawn is
pinned by the two rooks so we have Queen
takes rook pawn takes rook takes rook
check would be checkmate so Queen takes
bishop Queen takes work when's the
exchange and rook takes pawn to follow
is an easy ending to win so that's
that's the move I forgot about it
Bishop to h6 that is a great move now
there is a defense to the checkmate
besides Queen takes its bit pawn here
now white gets a winning position with
that with Bishop back my idea see so the
bishop wit now g6 weakened the pawns
around the black King see all those
black scores are very weak now the
bishop comes back and white wins that d6
pawn check and we use our little xscape
hatch I talked about the King moves up
and there's nothing black can do to save
the pawn and White's upon up black has
some drawing chances of a bishop of
opposite colors so it goes US the Queen
drops back the best if Rick takes pawn
that helps black defend because rook
takes rook with the rook off the board
there's less attacking chances so he
takes with the bishop to keep the rooks
on the board at least for a minute a few
moves now the Queen takes the pawn on c4
now there's a good move here
Bishop attacks the rook what happens if
the work does rook takes rook what's the
winning move for white going to be eight
check King to g7 what's the next move
eight checkmate
very good so he can't do work takes rook
so he just moves over then we put see
how the bishop is on f6 in those I told
you those black squares around the pawns
or week that if white can get his queen
to h6 it'll be checkmate Queen comes
here Rick comes up here now that black
tries to trade pawn up Queen here
forcing the bishop back this is the end
of the analysis so black has some
drawing chances because of a bishops of
opposite colors and whites only upon up
anyway White has a a bit a fairly good
advantage but he may not be able to win
let's go on to the next example okay
this position is roughly even the pawns
are even both pieces that both sides
have two minor pieces blacks rooks are
better developed than white because he
has both works out White has rook stuck
on f1 behind a pawn White's pawn
position is not as good as black see how
that pawn on c3 is by itself that's an
isolated pawn that's weakness in the
ending and the pawn on a2 is an isolated
pawn but given the fact that everything
else counter balances white can probably
hold so it's probably a drawing position
until black makes a couple of mistakes
the first mistake is Knight here
black tries to start an attack but he
doesn't he his King is still behind
those three pawns you see it's safer not
to move the knight yet what would be a
good move for black in this position not
to win the game just to defense Lee move
what would be a good black move
what could black do to alleviate the
fact that his King is stuck behind three
pawns can he make a hole for himself
yeah aged six aged six is the right move
it takes away all White's attacking
chances and it should be a draw and
black may be a little better
black neglected to do that and started
to try to attack and trade pieces
he played Knight to e5 now he does
threaten Knight takes bishop check but
look the white work on d1 and the Queen
on g5 are attacking that work on d800
just offended by the work the black rook
anyone in the Queen but also note that
the bishop on b7 is attacked so White's
going to try to draw the Queen away and
then play rook takes rook on d8 so a
white plays Bishop takes Bishop that
takes away the threat Knight takes
bishop check and if Queen takes bishop
now I can win with riff takes rook black
makes a blunder here black can still
draw the position
what's the drawing move for black
anybody have an idea
the I tell you the idea the idea is how
can black block that diagonal from the
Queen to the rook
once that diagonals blocked it takes
away the threat rook takes rook rook
takes Queen takes rook what's the move
f6 yes he should have played f6
reaching a drawn position instead he did
rook takes rook rook takes rook and
Queen takes and now we have Queen takes
Knight and the back rows undefended so
that's kind of cute
this position is interesting
notice that the queen ant the White
Queen and rook are headed toward King
Bishop 7 but it's defended by the black
Queen now the author thinks this is a
win for white but the computer which
wasn't around when the author made his
example back in 1935 the computer has a
defense so let's guess what White's
first move is the idea is to cut the
defensive line of the Queen on c4 to the
pawn on f7 who sees that move right now
the author makes a mistake and he thinks
that black is lost he actually says
black's best move is to sacrifice the
Queen for the work Queen takes her check
and obviously that's going to lose cuz
you keep you can't give up a queen and
only get a rook but there is a defense
who would Knight takes Knight that's
what the author plays and let's run
through that because that's kind of cute
Queen takes pawn check King over pawn up
threatening the Queen Queen drops back
to c3 Bishop here check bishop here now
the bishops pinned rights and the King's
wedged
behind pawns in that in the middle of
the board we sack our queen and get a
checkmate because the bishop can't go
back and defend it
so a Knight takes Knight doesn't work
but there is a defense would anyone like
to guess at the defense it's tricky
I didn't see it myself the computer is
better than we are actually so no I'm
going to show it to you
the threat is Queen takes pawn check the
pawn can't be defended if you can't
defend the pawn can you advance the pawn
to a better square not allowing the
Queen next to the King f5 and
surprisingly enough its defended by the
knight
so if pawn takes then the knight would
be free and we could either do Queen
takes our Knight takes winning the game
the best white can do now is get a draw
and it goes like this pawn here Queen
takes pawn Knight takes pawn check
Knight takes rook rook to g8 attacking
g2 with the Queen and work threatening
checkmate Bishop up to block the line of
the Queen Knight comes out preventing
the White Knight from retreating to c7
efore takes f5 and the Queen retreats to
the diagonal and the computer says this
is an even position and I just stopped
here but so it was a bust on our authors
example kind of interesting though okay
just a couple more this one is easy so
we can go through it really quickly
notice that the king is in a very bad
spot on f8 and that the rook is on g8
preventing the King from going to g8 and
retreating away
notice that that diagonal from the king
to the pawn a trip on that black
diagonal is open and that white Queen
could go to be for Queen to be for a
check
notice that the to the white rooks are
lined up like so the white works are
ready to pound rook to d8 at the right
moment so what's the winning move for
white well that's an interesting idea
but if rook takes where's your checkmate
I can go to e7 with my king well not
really because you would have the other
work to dese Evan would be checkmate
because the King can't go to e6 because
of the bishop so rook takes Queen
doesn't cut it going to be forged to the
authors and losers Queen takes pawn
interesting I'd have to look at it some
more Queen back now we have that so this
would be a possibility but then the
bishop comes here this is kind of pretty
check pawn comes up Bishop takes pawn
check pawn can't take the bishop because
we'd have Queen takes rook check Queen
takes rook takes the e pawn because the
Queen doesn't protect it and the King
can't go to f8 and can't go to the D
file so the Queen has to block the check
what's the winning move for whites
no not queen bee five
well Rick takes Queen check would
probably win but the author says Queen
2d six threatening the rook and rook
takes Queen pawn takes Queen takes pawn
check and the Queen would be on the
other work you see so the work to decent
the Queen to d6 is stronger because we
get the Queen into the attack and we win
a temple by attacking the rook on b8
which is unprotected alright let's go on
to our next example I think white wins
but rook here yeah it depends on black
makes a mistake Queen the f3 f6 this
should be a draw Queen takes pawn Queen
takes pawn on b7 still a draw rook down
a threatening Queen takes pawn on b7 now
black let's see
Oh black attacks the queen by attacking
the Queen it it sets up a trap and white
falls right into it
what white needs to retreat the Queen
there's two good squares for the Queen
the Queen could go to g3 see how it
would protect the pawn on f2 which is a
weak point the black orchid note black
queen are attacking the f2 so queen of
g3 would hold that but then the the rook
had come down to the second rank and
swing across you two have threatened
earth takes pawn there's a better move
than Queen to g3 the right move for
white is Queen to d6 and it's better
because the Queen if the work goes to c2
it would leave the work
f/8 we could do queen takes the FA
checkmate so let me show you what the
white got greedy and took the pawn
that's a blunder
what's the winning move for black right
Queen takes f2 rook takes
check check checkmate
this is our last example then I got a
problem I don't know if I'll have time
to do the problem but we'll try I think
we need to make some moves let's see
what happens rook here Queen down to d7
now the queen is on the rook on e8 rook
takes rook what's the one he moved for
white
right Queen to e8 rook takes rook takes
Bishop back now what's the winning move
Bishop to East
don't forget Queen takes her a check is
threatened rook to d8 would probably win
I don't see how black could defend but
there's a prettier move watch this move
rook takes Bishop check and work here is
checkmate
even better than rook there first okay
well that will do it for tonight thanks
for coming
[Music]
you
[Music]